[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم ربما لاول مره
تصبح محكمه العدل الدوليه محل اهتمام
للراي العام العربي السبب واضح وبسيط لان
جنوب افريقيا تمكنت من جرجره اسرائيل
للمثول امامها ما هي محكمه العدل الدوليه
ماذا فعلت جنوب افريقيا ما النتائج
المتوقعه من مثول اسرائيل امام هذه
المحكمه هذا موضوع حلقتنا اليوم اللي
بيشرف ن فيها الاستاذ الدكتور علي الدين
هلال المفكر السياسي المرموق والمعروف
مساء الخير معالي الدكتور مساء الخير يا
فندم اهلا وسهلا ربنا يخلي حضرتك يعيش يا
استاذ سعيد هل فاجاتك انه جنوب افريقيا
تجرجر اسرائيل لمحكمه العدل الدوليه قبل
ما نتكلم على ما هي محكمه العدل الدوليه
يعني طبعا يعني كان المتصور ان دول اخرى
قد يكون لها اا فضل السبق يعني كان او اول
حاجه ياتي لذه ان احدى الدول العربيه او
بعض الدول العربيه تقوم بهذا
الاجراء واذا مش الدول العربيه يعني مثلا
دوله زي ايران او تركيه عندها عقيده ثابته
ا ضد اسرائيل
وضد الكيان الس او تركيه انما ده ما
حصلش اللي حصل جاه من جنوب افريقيا دوله
غير
عربيه اغلبيتها لا تدين
بالاسلام انما هي رمز اخلاقي
ومعنوي كبير
جدا وعشان نفهم ليه يعني انت انت عندك
سؤالين هو ليه في جنوب افريقيا بدر بهذا
مضبوط يعني ليه قاد جنوب افريقيا المثقفين
المحامين الحكومه الاحزاب الحزب الحاكم
اللي هو حزب المؤتمر ليه خدوا هذا القرار
ليه اهتموا بهذا
الموضوع وم قبله قطع العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
ادانات الى اخره نتذكر اولا ان جنوب
افريقيا هي النموذج الابرز في القرن
العشرين للفصل
العنصري لسياسات التمييز
العنصر ان
منديلا قعد 27 سنه في السجن في سجن زعيم
الاسود التاريخي اللي
قاد يعني النضال لانهاء سياسات الفصل
العنصري و الحكومه البيضاء وخ جائزه نوبل
الى اخره ان هذا الزعيم التاريخي هو رمز
لفكره العداله فكره المساواه
البشريه فكره رفض التمييز
العنصري اذا
تق العقيده اللي تاسست
عليها دوله جنوب افريقيا هي عقيده
تحرر عقيده
معاديه للعدوان لعدم المساواه الى اخره
في حاجه تانيه بقى يعني يمكن اللي يعرفوها
عدد قليل
وهو في التاريخ في القرن 19
هرتزل
مؤسس الفكره
الصهيونيه كان صديق لواحد اسمه جنرال
سمتس
مؤسس دوله جنوب افريقيا
العنصريه وهناك افكار
عديده مشتركه بين الفكره الصهيونيه في
علاقتها بسكان فلسطين
وفكره النظام العنصري في علاقته
بالافق اللي هي او علاقه تقوم على
الاستعلاء ان ان احنا الجنس بتاعنا افضل
من في الحاله دي اليهود
والفلسطينيين في الحاله الثانيه البيض
والسود الحاجه الثانيه استعلاء اه لكن
عايز اشغلكم
لصالحنا وفي مرحله اخرى الفصل
العنصري انت لما تتامل في مفهوم الجدار
العازل اللي اسرائيل
عملته من نهايه القرن الماضي ود راح
المحكمه لما يجي المناسبه يقول لك الواقعه
يعني بقوم على فكره الفصل
العنصري الجار الجدار اللي بنته اسرائيل
علشان يحيط به السكان الفلسطينيين مضبوط
كده
اه هي معزل يعني عزل السكان الفلسطينيين
عن اسرائيل والاسرائيليه اذا بقى في
بوابات عليك ان انت تجتازها لكي تنتقل من
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله الى الى داخل
اسرائيل
ا وعلى مدى التاريخ
كان في صلات
وثيقه بين الحركه الصهيونيه المنظمه
الصهيونيه العالميه والنظام العنصري في
جنوب افريقيا فايضا هم يعني الى جانب ان
هم رمز للمساواه والتحرر ورفض العدوان هم
ايضا يدركون
ويعرفون الصله التاريخيه والعلاقات
التاريخيه بين اسرائيل ومن قبلها الحركه
الصهيونيه مع ان النظام العنصري في الذي
كان يحجم جنوب افريقيا حتى مطلع التسعينات
فاذا لما حضرتك بتقول ان دوله جنوب
افريقيا الان بعد انتهاء الفصل العنصري هي
بتحاول ان تكون نموذجا اخلاقيا في العالم
يعني يعني هي كده هي يعني تتمتع الان
بالرده الاخلاقيه في العالم ما لسم احنا
انا مش فاهم دي معال الدكتور تتمتع بمعنى
ان هي تتمنى تتمتع ولا هي بتتمتع
ممارساتها
الممارسات التي تقوم بها دوله جنوب
افريقيا هي نموذج راقي
ومتميز للسمو
الاخلاقي
وللرياضة ال المقيت في بدايه التسعينات
بدايه التسعينات طبعا نذكر الشباب اللي
ربما يكون صغيرا يعني لا يتذكر التاريخ
الحديث حتى انه جنوب افريقيا كانت
تجربه استعمار استيطاني استط مضبوط زي زي
اليهود وانه البيض المستعمرين جاؤوا من
دول اوروبيه مختلفه فاستولوا على اراضي
جنوب افريقيا ذلوا شعبها لسنوات لعشرات
السنوات يعني الى ان تحرروا من حكومه
الفصل العنصري في مطلع التسعينات مظبوط
معال الدكتور مظبوط مظبوط طب هذا هو السبب
او هذان هما السببان الاول انه دوله جنوب
افريقيا بعد انتهاء نظام الفصل العنصري في
بدايه التسعينات تشعر ان عليها واجبا
اخلاقيا مبوط تجاه قضايا كثيره منها ان
تحارب السياسات الاستعماريه اللي منها او
على راسها اللي هي اليهود في ا على
الاراضي الفلسطينيه الامر الثاني انه ان
هم كانوا يدركوا ان الحركه الصهيونيه كانت
قرينا او صديقا للنظام الذي استعبدهم
لقرون طويله احسنت طيب ده جميل جدا بس
الشق الثاني من السؤال
ايه لماذا لم تبادر دول كثيره كانت يعني
في مكان يمكنها من ان تفعل عده اسباب عده
اسباب دون يعني تحديد مين كده الدول اللي
احنا ذكرناها يعني الدول العربيه وتركيا
وايران بعض هذه الدول متهمه في تاريخها
لارس اعمال عنيفه جدا
اه يعني تركيا متهمه مش تركيا الدوله
الحديثه تركيا ايام الحرب العالميه الاولى
حدثت مجازر للارمن ا اول اول مجزره كبرى
في القرن الع للاباده الجماعيه كان ما حدث
في
ارمن في الفتره ما بين انتهاء الدوله
العثمانيه ومولد الجمهوريه التركيه
الحديثه سنه
1923 تحديدا اثناء الحرب العالميه الاولى
1915 لغايه 22 23 فحصلت مجازر ما زالت حيه
حتى الان وفي عديد من دول
العالم البرلمانات يعني البرلمان الفرنسي
البرلمان الامريكي من لاث اربع سنين
الكونجرس يصدر قرار
بالاعتراف
بوجود الاباده الجماعيه ل الارمن من جانب
الاتراك تجاه الارمن اثناء الحرب العالميه
الاولى تركيه بترد تقول لك اولا ده مش
احنا اللي عمل ده كانت القاضه العسكريين
في الدوله العثمانيه ايا كان فانت عندك
يعني احدى هذه الدول متهمه
به بد الج جماعيه بعض الدول صحيح ما عملتش
اباده جماعيه لكن ما عندهاش يعني نظم
الحكم فيها وممارستها
السياسيه احترامها حقوق الانسان لا يؤهلها
ان ترفع قضيه زي كده مفهوم يعني هي مجروحه
ا دوله زي ايران عليها العقوبات وكذا وكذا
فما بين بعض الدول ربما تخشى من عواقب هذا
ان ده هيغضب اسرائيل فاذا كنت بتشتري حاجه
من
اسرائيل تغرب امريكا لو لك اعتماد على
امريكا ف ما بين مخاوف على من جانب حكومات
هذه الدول على
مصالحها ما بين ان احداها متهمه باباده
جماعيه واسعه النطاق او انها في اوضاعها
السياسيه والاجتماعيه عيه فيها ممارسات لا
تجعلها مؤهله اخلاقيا للقيام بهذا الدور
كده الاجابه واضحه جدا الاجابه واضحه جدا
طب اما وقد قلنا ذلك نذهب بقى الى يعني
الحدث الرئيسي نعم معلوماتي معلوماتنا ان
جنوب
افريقيا اخذت اسرائيل لمحكمه العدل
الدوليه
ا لشقين او لامرين الامر الاول مطالبه
بوقف فوري للحرب الدائره هناك والامر
الثاني اتهام اسرائيل بارتكاب اباده
جماعيه هل ممكن نتكلم الاول على المحكمه
ولماذا تنظر في هذه القضايا ا نعم حاضر ا
دول سؤالين السؤال الاول ايه هي هذه
المحكمه اه كان حلم الدول
ا من نهايه يعني منذ تبلور ظاهره الدوله
في اوروبا ثم في العالم ان يوجد محكمه لحل
الخلافات بين دول العالم يعني ما هو
الفارق الرئيسي بين الدوله في المحيط
الداخلي والعلاقات
الدوليه الدوله يعني مصر سوريا العراق
السعوديه الامارات توجد سلطه
امره في كل من هذه الدول في شرطه وفي
قضاء ده معناه فكره السلطه الامره ان في
سلطه
تضع قانون وفي هيئات
البرلمان وفي هيئات تنفذ هذا القانون
الشرطه تقبض عليك تروح المحكمه تحكم
عليك في العلاقات الدوليه لا توجد هذه
السلطه
الامره يعني قبل القرن العش اصلا مافيش
تنظيم
دولي كان في تنظيمات في اوروبا بعد الحرب
العالميه الاولى نشات عصبه الامم عصب الام
اول تنظيم دولي اول تنظيم دولي على
المستوى الدولي اه اه وعصبه الد الامم
انشات محكمه عتق اسمها المحكمه الدائمه
للعدل الدولي قبل المحكمه بتاعتنا دي كان
المقصود بها هي الذراع
القانوني للتنظيم
الدولي هذه
المحكمه يعني اخر اجتماع ليها
ا كان بقى مع تحدي الدول لها عدم صياحه
اصلا للمثول
امامها وفي منتصف الثلاثينات توقفت عن
العمل بعد نشوب الحرب العالميه الثانيه او
اقتراب الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وبدات الدول تمارس سياسات القوه
الغاشمه كان من ابرز الحاجات دي قيام
ايطاليا
بغزو اثيوبيا كان اسمها
الحبشه
ودون
اعتبار لا لميثاق عصبه الامم
ولا من القرن الماضي ثلاثينيات القرن
الماضي اعتقد سنه
1933 الغزو الايطالي ثوبيا لاثيوبيا اللي
كان اسمها وقتها
الحبشه الحرب العالميه التانيه حصلت
انتهت اجتمع
المنتصرون الدول المنتصره وتعريف دول
المنتصره طبعا قمتهم الخمس
دول الولايات المتحده الاتحاد السوفيتي
الصين بريطانيا فرنسا زائد كل الدول التي
اعلنت الحرب على المحور خلال
الحرب فاجتمع عدد كبير من الدول في في
مؤتمر سان فرانسيسكو الذي انشا الامم
المتحده المؤتمر ده مثلا حضره ا الامير
فيصل اللي هو عليه رحمه الله الملك فيصل
فيصل ابن عبد العزيز كان هو لسه في مقتب
حياته في هذا الوقت كان هو رئيس الوفد
السعودي حضر من مصر عبد الحميد بدوي اللي
هو وزير العدل واللي هو لعب دور
رئيسي في صياغه المواد المتعلقه بالمنظمات
الدوليه لانه كانت جامعه الدول العربيه
سبقت الامم المتحده في يقولوا طب ايه شكل
التنظيم الدولي وعلاقه التنظيم الدولي
بالتنظيم الاقليمي كان هو الضور كان في
ايضا
اللبناني ورجل قانوني شارل مالك العرب
كانوا موجودين في هذه في هذه
المباحثات وصدر ميثاق الامم ميثاق منظمه
الامم المتحده تحت اللي هو
بقى المنظمه التي ورثت عصبه الامم سنه كام
صدر الميثاق 45 1945 تمام
دلوقتي وده تنضم عليه الدول انشا ايه
الامم المتحده دي
بقى خمس هيئات هيئه اسمها مجلس
الامن تكون من 15 واحد خمسه دائمين وع
بالانتخاب والخامسه اللي هي دول منتصره
احتفظت لنفسها بحق
الفي الحاجه الثانيه الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده اللي هي يعني الجمعيه العامه كل
الدول فيها وكل الدول لها صوت واحد ال 193
ده مضبوط اه وبعدين حاجه اسمها المجلس
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي اللي هو ذراع ده
موجود وفي لجان كثيره ذراع الامم المتحده
المتعلق بالتنميه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
المجلس الاقتصادي والاجتماعي رقم اربعه
اربعه وده اندثر حاجه اسمها مجلس الوصايه
انه كان فكره الوصايه على الدول يعني ايه
المستعمرات للدول التي هزمت يعني لما هزم
المانيا وايطاليا واليابان كانت لها
مستعمرات طب ما هو مصير هذه المستعمرات
تدار بواسطه الامم المت متحده من خلال
مجلس الوصايه ميه منها مثلا ليبيا كانت
تحت الوصايه
ا الصومال تحت
الوصايه والمجلس يدير يعمل
انتخابات الهيئه الخامسه اسمها محكمه
العدل الدوليه
اه هي الذراع
القانوني
القضائي اولا كيف يختار القضاه بتوعها
يختاروا بالانتخاب بالاختيار من مجلس
الامن والجمعيه
العامه يعني يعني يتم تصويت طبعا وفي
اتصالات دبلوماسيه لضمان التمثيل الى اخره
الا تتكون من 15 قاضي
قاضي من كل الدول
بقى يعني التشكيل الحالي مثلا فيه ثلاث
قضاه من دول عربيه المغرب المغرب والصومال
الصومال
لبنان الوضع الحالي بتاعنا دلوقتي بينتخب
واحد منهم رئيس اللي
هو القاضيه الامريكيه هي رئيسه المحكمه
الان حسب اجراءات المحكمه
دي زي الوضع بتاعنا لو هتبص في الصوره
بتاعه المحكمه هتم مش 15 تم 17 اه طب
الاتنين دول جم منين لما يكون في دعوه زي
كده من
حق طرفي النزاع يعينوا القاضي اه ان يمثله
في
وبالتالي الاساسيين بالاضافه لجنوب افريقي
واسرائيلي مبوط كده عظيم جدا دي معلومه
مهمه ط دلوقتي بقى
حضرتك المحكمه دي دورها ايه لها ادور
عديده بنص الميثاق او اول حاجه ممكن انها
اذا في دولتين دولتين اتفقوا مع بعضهم على
ان هم يطرحوا خلاف معين امام المحكمه
المحكمه تنظر فيه وتحكم فيه ويصبح قرارها
ملزم لدولتين الحاجه
الثانيه ان
انت دوله من الدول تقول انا في موضوع
نزاعي في خلاف تقول انا هلتزم بالالزام
القانوني للمحكمه اه يعني هلجا للمحكمه
والتزم بما تق او انا ده اللي مصر عملته
في سنه 56 لما تم تاميم شركه قناه السويس
والدنيا هاجت وان زي مصر يعني الوضع
بتاعها وكذا ازاي نضمن احترامها للقانون
الدولي ازاي نضمن حريه الملاحه في القناه
فمصر قالت
اناقبل بال
بالتزام
باحكام اللي تصدرها محكمه العدل في هذا
الموضوع يبقى يصبح من حق اي دوله انها وده
حصل بالفعل يعني ما حصلش حاجه بعد كده ان
مصر احترمت ان مصر احترمت قواعد المرور
البريء في القناه اه لكن لو مصر انتهكت
هذا من حق اي دوله في العالم انها تنازعها
في
المحكمه يعني انا بقبل بقول يا اخوانا انا
انتوا اتشكين فيا او عندي مشاكل ا انا
بقبل بالالتزام بالالزام
القانوني للمحكمه في هذا الموضوع يعني في
حال اذا حصل اي نزاع من اي دوله عاوزه
تعبر حول هذا الموضوع صح حول قناه السويس
فن الجا لمحكمه العوده الدوليه وسوف التزم
دون موافقه مني د موافقه
يعني برض بحكم الميثاق المحكمه لها ان
تعطي ما يسمى الراي
الاستشاري بس الراي الاستشاري دوت يطلب من
الجمعيه العامه او مجلس الامن وده اللي
حصل في 2003 2004 ان الجمعيه العامه طلبت
من مجلس من من المحكمه النظر في موضوع
يعني باغلبيه اعضاء الجمعيه العامه
الجمعيه العامه حولت موضوع الجدار العازل
الى الذي بنته اسرائيل بالضبط كان لسه
بتبنيه خلص اذا الى المحكمه من يطلب الر
الاستشاري المحكمه يا مجلس الامن مش دوله
معينه تقول لها انا عاوزه رايك او برض لو
دولتين اتفقوا عايزين يطلبوا الراي
الاستشار عظيم جدا عظيم جدا ايه بقى لكن
دلوقتي الحادثه اللي معانا دي دلوقتي
مالهاش
علاقه
بالاختصاصات الوارده في ميثاق الامم
المتحده احنا الخلاف اللي بين دلوقتي بقى
يتعلق
بتنفيذ
اتفاقيه وقعت عام
48 اسمها
اتفاقيه منع جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه ومعاقبه
مرتكبيها دي
اتفاقيه وقعت في عام
48 بدا تنفيذها سريانها عام 50 المعاهده
دي بتقول ايه
يعني الماده الاولى بتقول تعتبر
جريمه الاباده الجماعيه جريمه يعقب عليها
القانون
وحددت ايه هي
الافعال اللي
تعتبر ممارسات للاباده الجماعيه ا ب ج د
وحددت في الماده
الثالثه مين هم من يمكن تسميتهم
قانونيا
اطراف الاباده الجماعيه قالت مثلا انه
هتستغرب حضرتك ان مثلا اي اجراء من من
شانه منع
التوالد ان مجموع او ايه تعريف الاباده
الجماعيه هي ممارسات اباده تتم ضد مجموعه
بشريه دينيه عرقيه اثنيه قوميه طب هتعمل
معاهم ايه اولا ان انت تمنع عنهم مصادر
الحياه الاساسيه الميه الاكل الغذاء الى
اخره انك تمارس اعمال قتل وعنف دون تمييز
بين افراد هذه
الجماعه لاثه انك تتخذ اجراءات من شانها
منع المواليد او منع التوالد بين
ابناء هذه المجموعه يمنع التولد ازاي يعني
يعني في ح تعمل تعقي
اه يعني انك تعمل على انقاص عدد اه هذه
المجموعه الفصل بين الرجال والنساء انما
دي يعني مذكوره احد عناصر الاباده
الجماعيه
الحيلوله الحيلوله من ان تقوم اي جماعه
بشريه
بالتوالد الطبيعي او ديكان له الاستمرار
مما يكفل لها
الاستمرار بعد كده بتعقب مين يا سيدي من
ارتكبوها من شاركوا في ارتكابها من خططوا
لتنفيذها من حرضوا عليها
اه يعني
كله من امروا
بها اللي نفذ اللي امر اللي
شارك اللي حرد اللي تامر على
حدوثها او من حاول
ارتكابها حاول ولم يوفق ف يعني ميثاق جدير
بالاحترام يعني في يريد ان
ينهي بس عايز اقول
ايه هو يعني اذا في
حرب ترتب عليها اشياء او نتائج
ا
شديده
الوطاه على المدنيين ده في حد ذاته لا يعد
اباده
جماعيه العنصر
الحاسم في توجيه التهمه
النيه ان انت يقع في ضمير المحكمه والقضاه
ان الذين ارتكبوا هذه الاحداث ارتكبوها
بنيه الاباده الجماعيه ففي مساحه للتاويل
يعني في مساحه طبعا اه وده يعني ممكن
اهوال تقع لشعب ما ولكن المحكمه ترى ان
هذا لم يك متعمدا انه كان نتيجه طبيعيه
لاعمال العنف التي سدت في هذه البلاد اه
وان الجرائم دي حصلت على الطرفين اه
وان ده اللي بتقوله تركيه على كل الاحوال
في الدفاع عن نفسها من جريمه الاباده
الجمعيه في الارمن اه فانت عايزز تثبت ان
الذين خططوا للحرب
كان في ذهنهم
هذا ويمكن بدا يقودنا الى ايه اللي عمليته
جنوب
افريقيا انا بس هستاذن حضرتك ان ده سؤال
مهم جدا اذا المحكمه موجوده ثم
تمت الاتفاق الاتفاقيه منع الاباده
الجماعيه وعهد الى محكمه العدل الدوليه
بتولي الاشراف على هذه الاتفاقيه تنفيذها
وتنفيذها المعاهده دي دلوقتي النهارده
يعني هي لما
وقعت نصت على ايه انت بتوقع وتصدق يعني في
المعادلات الدوليه افترض ان وزير الخارجيه
راح مضى لا ده لا يكفي لازم البرلمان
البرلمان يرجع اسود تصديق فهم قالوا وقتها
سنه 48 لما نشا الفيه دي انه تصبح ساريه
عندما يتم تصديق 20 دوله وده اللي حصل سنه
50 عظيم جدا الدول الاتفاقيه دي النهارده
حضرتك فيها حوالي
153 دوله
دوله بعض
الدول مضت على على على شي على بياض يعني
التزمت منها اسرائيل ومنها جنوب افريقيا
يعني وقعوا وصدقوا دون وضع اي تحفظات عظيم
جدا بعض الدول
العربيه لما صدقت حطوا
تحفظات ده من حقك تبقى انت موقع مثلا الا
في حاله يعني مثلا هقوللك حاجه تانيه في
موضوعات حقوق الانسان والكلام ده كله اغلب
الدول العربيه لما بتصدق عليها تقولك الا
فيما يتعلق بالحريه الدينيه او
بالسب المقدسات يعني اه في حريه فكر الا
في كذا وكذا كذا فمن حقك انك تتحفظ
وبالتالي لما تطبق الاتفاقيه بيشوف ايه
التحفظ اللي انت عامله اللي انت عامله
وراعيه
وراعيه اسرائيل حكم تحمسها وجنوب افريقيا
بحكم الماضي بتاعها سلموا بالاتفاقيه دون
اي تحفظات وده اللي اعطى الحق القانوني
لجنوب افريقيا ان ترفع القضيه على اسرائيل
ان البلدين موقعين على اتفاقيه اذا اصبحوا
شركاء في هذه
الاتفاقيه وبالتالي من الناحيه
القانونيه حكومه جنوب افريقيا تتهم
اسرائيل بانها خالفت انتهكت الالتزامات
القانونيه المترتبه على معاهده الاباده
الجماعيه وباعتبار انها هي طرف في
الاتفاقيه وانا طرف الاتفاقيه برفع عليك
هذه
القضيه
والجنوب افريقيا لها مطلبين ما هما
المطلبين مطلبين حسب ال
الاتفاقيه لما ترفع
قضيه المحكمه بتعمل
حاجتين بتستمع اليك لصاحب الدعوه ساعتين
لاثه اليوم التالي تستمع الى
رد من موجهت اليه التهمه ساعتين
ثلاثه
ثم تعتكف عاده اسبوعين ثلاثه 17 ضي اه 17
قاضي
ويصدر ما يسمى التدابير
الاحترازيه وقرار عاجل زي ما احنا ساعات
في القانون مثلا في بلادنا العربيه نقول
ايه الشق المستعجل الشق المستعجل يعني
يقوللك ابقاء الامر على ما هو عليه تمكين
صاحب الشقه من كذا او تمكين المستاجر
عاجل ده بيصدر في
خلال شهر او اقل او
اكتر وفي هذه الحاله الشق العاجل هو وقف
وف الاطلاق عظيم وده المطلب الاول لجنوب
افريقيا لكن ده لا يعني اثبات التهمه اه
لكن بيعني ان هناك من الشبهات هناك من
الدلائل ما يشير ان في اساس لهذا
الموضوع ثم في مايتعلق بقى بالموضوع
اي اتهام اسرائيل او تبرئه اسرائيل ده
ياخد له ب سنتين ارتكاب جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه يعني ادي حضرتك مثلا مثال
ا في احنا عندنا في ايه في
24 فبراير 22 بدات الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه على طول بعدها بشهر او شهرين
اوكرانيا تقدمت بطلب في مارس في مارس
تقدمت بطلب نفس الشيء
تتهم روسيا ب بارتكاب الاباده الجماعيه
وبالفعل على طول برض بعدها باسبوع صدر
الحكم
بوقف يعني صدر الحكم ضد روسيه بوقف كذا
انما ماخدتش قرار في الجانب الموضوعي اه
هل هيما اصت هذا القرار هل روسيا تورطت ام
لا لا بالضبط كده احنا قدامنا سؤالين
اعتقد يكون كده الصوره اكتملت تماما
الصوره الاولانيه هل قرارات المحكمه ملزمه
ام لا الامر الثاني
كم تتوقع ان يطول المداولات لكي تصدر
الحكم الامر الثالث ماذا تتوقع من حكم قد
يصدر بشان اسرائيل يعني ثلاث اسئله من
السؤالين اول سؤال يعني من ناحيه قرار
المحكمه ملزم لكن لا توجد سلطه تنفيذيه
لتنفيذه
مفهوم لكن هو هو قرار
ملزم ملزم من الناحيه القانونيه ولكن لا
توجد الاداه
التنفيذيه اللي تقوم عليه تقوم عليه لانه
لو صدر ضد رئيس دوله فالمفروض ان هيرسل
جيوش مثلا ليس لديهم جيوش لكن اذا حل هذا
الرئيس او المسؤول في دوله ملتزمه
بالاتفاقيه يمكن ان تقبض عليه مظبوط مضبوط
مظبوط او تتغاضى عنه او تتغاضى عن ذلك افي
بقى تلاعبات كتيره حضرتك يعني مثلا يقولوا
ايه اذا اذا الوزير ده او ورئيس الدوله ده
جاي في مهمه رسميه بوصف رئيس دوله مش من
حقك تقبض عليه اه انما لو
جاي يعني زياره خاصه تعمل على كده فطبعا
اللي بيحدث ان اي تحركات ا تذكر مثلا ا
الرئيس البشير اه عمر البشير رئيس السودان
السابق لا وبعد كده سافر في كل الدول
العربيه ما حصلش مهمه رسميه ان هو بيتصرف
او بيتنقل باعتباره رئيسا للدوله وبتالي
له حصانه معينه او شيء من هذا القبيل طب
هذا اجابه السؤال الاول السؤال الثاني ايه
بقى السؤال الثاني هل تتوقع حضرتك كم تطول
المداولات علشان يبثوا في الشق الموضوعي
لا الموضوعي ده سنوات ممكن اربع خمس سنوات
يعني ما حدش يعرف اه وعاده اه عاده يعني
انه بقى يعني عشان تثبت
النيه مساله محتاجه تشوف مداولات القرار
اتقال فيه ايه محاضر اجتماعات وده اللي
اللي جنوب افريقيا حاولت
تعمله يعني مثلا جابت فيديو لجنود
اسرائيليين بيغنوا
اه وقالوا طب هو ايه الاغنيه
دي اغنيه
تلمود ان حسب العهد
القديم لما اليهود خرجوا من مصر قدام
اليهود
ودخلوا ارض
فلسطين التلمود العهد القديم وفقا لروايته
وانا محدد
جدا طلب منهم ان يقتلوا جميع
الناس
سكان هذه المناطق ده كلام العهد القديم
التلمود و في اغنيه
بيغنوها اسطوره من
الاساطير
استخدم الجنوب
افريقيا لازم لازم الواحد يشيد بقى مش بس
بالسمو الاخلاقي او الرياده الاخلاقيه
وال المعلمه
القانونيه ان هذه الاغنيه احتراف هذه
الاغنيه المبنيه على قناعات دينيه تثبت
النيه داخل ان هو جاي بالضبط كده داخل
علشان اعمل اباده جماعيه وفقا لمفاهيم
وقناعات الدينيه اه بعد كده مثلا
ا اقتباسات بالصوت من قاده اسرائيل اه سوف
نن عنهم المياه الكهرباء الطاقه للا نسبح
بالدواء اه الدواء فيش
دواء لما يثبت
التاخر والمماطله في ادخال المسادا في
ادخال المساعدات
ويبدا بقى حضرتك مش كلام ز زي بيقول احنا
دلوقتي
في في التسجيل هيقول مثلا
ادي
العربه فلانيه اللي بتحمل
رقم كذا كذا خرجت من معبر رفح يوم كذا ما
وصلتش الا بكذا الا بعد كذا يوم او هو
طبعا بتروح ينقلوها في عربه فلسطينيه ايوه
عربه اسرائيليه عربه اسرائيليه فهو بيتكلم
على المط
في اجراءات التفتيش والموافقه على مشمولات
هذه العربات فانت لازم اذا هو يعلم هيقول
هيجيب ادله من كل كبار المسؤولين في الام
المتحده بعضهم اتكلم على الباده الجماعيه
المفوض السامي للاجئين رئيس الونر رئيس
منظمه الصحه العالميه رئيس اليونيسيف رئيس
المراه كل دول شاهد على تورد اسرائيل
واستخدموا الفاظ ان هذه السياسات تؤدي الى
كذا ان هذه السياسات تهدد بالعباده
الجماعيه فايضا بقى دول موظفين
دوليين فايضا يبقى ايه يعني صوتهم له وقع
وص طبعا طبعا ا قد ايه بقى هياخد دوت هو
طبعا المفروض ان هؤلاء القضاه محيدين انما
طبعا السياسه
لها تداخلات
وتقاطعات يعني مثلا شوف الاسراع اسراع
المحكمه في اصدار قرار يتعلق بروسيا
بينما قد يتاخر الامر في بعض الاحيان فيما
يتعلق باسرائيل انا بعتقد انه يعني في
خلال شهر على الاكثر
من الرد الاسرائيلي هنستمر الى راي من
جانب القرار بتاع المحكمه الشق المستعجل
الشق المستعجل اللي هو وقف الحرب اللي هو
وقف الحرب ثم ننتظر عده سنوات لصدور
القرار النهائي فيما يتعلق بمدى تورد
اسرائيل من عدمه في تهمه او جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه مضبوط انا عايز اقول بس حاجه او
حاجتين في الاخر
ا
يعني اسرائيل
ظلت منذ 48 حتى
الان دوله فوق
القانون منذ
بدايتها لم تحترم قرارات
الهدنه وانتهاكاتها ده في بدايه الص 48
اه اسرائيل هي الدوله التي
تم ادانه سلوكياتها وافعالها اكثر دوله في
العالم على مدى ال 70 سنه اللي
فاتت اسرائيل كان
لديها مش عايز يعني الجراه انها ترفض
مطالب يعني امميه ان عايزين يبعت لجنه
تقصي الحقائق حول موضوع من الموضوعات فهي
ترفض دي من المرات يعني عايز اقول 11 و12
يناير 20
24 يومين تاريخيين اللي ههم شهد جرجره
اسرائيل لمحكمه العدل الدوليه واجبارها
على انها اولا ان
لمده مده
طويله الفريق الجنوب افريقي ب
يدين سلوكيات
وافعال
اسرائيل
من غير
عواطف الكلمه الهادئه
الوثائق الملف بتاعهم في 84
صفحه
و
الرد اللي غلبت عليه دفوع سياسيه اللي هو
شغله المحكمه اه كلام اسرائيليين كلام
سياسي ماهواش كلام سياسي
اه يعني
ا وان احنا يعني لم يكن يعني من زاويه
حرفيه بحته
لم يكن لديه الصلابه القانونيه او التماسك
القانوني الذي كان لي جنوب افريقيا انا
راي الحته دي ان تقف اسرائيل
متهمه في جريمه هي بتعتبر
نفسها اكبر تحيه ليها من تضرر منها واكبر
من من يدينها في العالم الاباده الجماعيه
الاباده الجماعيه يعني دي
في
حضرتك فيلسوف الماني كبير قوي اسمه هيجل
اه طبعا فريدريك
هيجل فده اتكلم على سخريه
التاريخ يعني في التاريخ ده
مفارقات في يعنيي هيسجل التاريخ ان
اسرائيل الدوله التي
دائما
رفعت وبررت سلوكها باسم المظلوميه
التاريخيه وحرص
على تذكير العالم وابتزاز
العالم بالمحرك
اليهوديه ان هذه
الدوله تقف وقفت يوم 11 و12 يناير
متهمه
بارتكاب جريمه الاباده الجماعيه السؤال
الاخير يا مع على الدكتور اذا كان لي
اجابه هل تتوقع في ظل ان بيبقى في
اعتبارات سياسيه كثيره في يعني برض بتؤثر
على احكام القضاه في هذه المحكمه وغيرها
من المنظمات الدوليه ان تدان اسرائيل ام
لا تدان لا الادان في الاخر خالص لا
ماعرفش طيب لا لا طب في كل الاحوال سواء
ادانت المحكمه اسرائيل ام لم تدنه هل
تعتقد حضرتك واستاذن يعني في اجابه موجزه
هل تعتقد ان الضرر قد حدث بالفعل لاسرائيل
قوله واحده ضرر فادح
بسمعتها خد بالك يعني يجوز دلوقتي المجتمع
العربي ل ين داش دي سمعت كذا كذا لا ده
عندنا احنا بس لا في الغرب في اوروبا لا
صورتها انها دوله شريفه
واستراليا لا سمعتها طيبه وهي نجحت في نقل
رسالتها وتشويه سوره نجحت فيه ان السرديه
الاسرائيليه للاحداث هي هي هي السرديه
الاكثر قبولا في العالم لغايه يوم 7
اكتوبر
النهارده تحول الراي العام الدولي في شكل
مظاهرات الى اخره لكن مش في الطبقه
السياسيه او الحكام في دول
اوروبا ودول
غربيه المحكمه جت يعني تقول كده بقى القشه
التي قصمت ان في ادام مش كلام سياسي
وبيانات صحفيه ومظاهرات في الش شارع
واعلانات وشعارات انما مساله قانونيه امام
محكمه امام اعلى
محكمه وهيئه قضائيه في العالم نعم اضرت
باسرائيل
وبسمعها وبصورته وباقا وها في العالم ضررا
بليغا سوف تاخذ وقت كبير لعلاجه وهذا احد
انجازات ما تم بدايه من 7 اكتوبر نعم انا
جزيل الشكر معال الدكتور اديتنا اطلاله
عظيمه يعني على البعد التاريخي
وال سواء للاتفاقيه او للمحكمه واستشراف
للمستقبل لما قد يحدث اكرر شكري شكرا
جزيلا ربنا يخلي حضرتك ونلتقي ان شاء الله
في حلقات اخرى كثيره نتعلم فيها من حضرتك
ربنا يخليك وتشكر قوي قوي قوي ربنا يخلي
حضرتك شكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم ونلقاكم على
خير في حلق مقبله باذن الله